estoy organizando mis actividades y me
gustaría que me ayudarás como lo haremos
he pensado que podemos y describiéndolas
en un calendario sabes para qué sirve un
calendario nos ayuda a organizar el
tiempo en este caso los días las semanas
los meses y los años empecemos poco a
poco entre semana separó mis días en
tres partes por la mañana voy a la
escuela por la tarde realizó alguna
actividad extra y por la noche hago
tarea aunque no todos los días de la
semana hago las mismas actividades como
se forma una semana el primer día de la
semana es el domingo le sigue el lunes
martes miércoles jueves viernes y por
último sábado si contamos día por día
nos damos cuenta que una semana tiene 7
días
para organizar todas las actividades de
una semana me gusta empezar por el lunes
los lunes además de ir a la escuela
juego basketball y después me dedico a
hacer tarea el martes voy a la escuela
por la mañana más tarde voy a casa de un
amigo porque estamos aprendiendo a
pintar y luego hago tarea miércoles
escuela otra vez basketball y tarea
jueves escuela basketball y tarea el
viernes tengo un día más tranquilo
porque solo voy a la escuela y sábado y
domingo no tengo ninguna actividad en
especial listo ahora que está en mis
actividades en el calendario es más
fácil ver que de los 7 días de la semana
cinco días voy a la escuela dedico
cuatro hacer tarea 3 a básquetbol y solo
un día de la semana voy a casa de mi
amigo a pintar que bien así no se me
pasarán mis actividades y se abre mejor
cuando me toca hacerlas esto se repite
cada semana
- el último viernes del mes que
presentamos a nuestras familias nuestros
trabajos de pintura
cuando será mi próxima presentación si
hoy es viernes 6 para avanzar una semana
debo sumar 7 porque recuerda cada semana
tiene 7 días así sé que el siguiente
viernes se estrese sumó otro ab7 y llego
al viernes 20 por último otro 7 y bien
viernes 27 será mi próxima presentación
hay que marcarlo en el calendario ahora
por mucha atención como tengo una
presentación al mes al año son 12 pero
por qué porque un año tiene 12 meses
veamos cuáles son enero febrero marzo
abril mayo junio julio agosto septiembre
octubre noviembre y diciembre observa no
todos los meses tienen los mismos días
algunos meses tienen cuatro o cinco
semanas 30 o 31 días aunque tenemos el
mes de febrero con 28 días
en otro vídeo te explicaremos por qué
revisa tu calendario y no dejes que te
sorprendan te invito a que sigas
practicando con el calendario busca los
días que no vas a la escuela porque se
conmemora una fecha importante los
cumpleaños de tu familia el inicio de
clases las vacaciones y muchas fechas
más